So you're in a museum looking at
Picasso,
you've heard the name a million times,
you know the influence,
you know,
he's one of the most important artists
of the 20th century.
You know,
he invented cubism,
you know,
he loved women,
lots of women,
and you know,
he wasn't that great to them.
You know,
he had phases,
the blue period,
the rose period,
neoclassicism.
So realism,
but the painting,
you're looking at,
the one in front of you,
you've never seen it before,
and it's called night fishing at
antibodies or on tv,
you don't really know.
You don't speak French,
a little card next to it doesn't say
much,
but you want to know more about it.
How?
The way I see it,
you can look at any Picasso in five
different ways.
The first and often,
the best way to understand any painting
is simply to look at it.
Describe to yourself the objects and the
actions that you see the night fishing.
For example,
what you see as to spear fisherman,
hunting for fish from a small boat,
but by a mesmerizing light at the top of
the canvas.
One fisherman leans strongly into the
water with his spear hesitating before
delivering the final blow to a fish.
All the other liens languidly over the
edge looking anxious.
The fishing line tied to his foot.
In the upper left,
we can see two towers and a massive
purple shape swell around the fisherman
fly moths or insect slipped by the
light,
curving over the back of one of them
toward the right side of the frame where
two women,
one with an ice cream cone and a bicycle
gesture to the men who don't seem to
notice that much.
I find my first reactions to this entire
painting to be a bit contradictory.
On the one hand,
there seems to be a violent foreboding
character to the scene.
The central focus is clearly the hand
and the spear and the fish,
but there also seems to be an
equilibrium here in the balance of
colors and figures and almost magical
view into an all too ordinary activity
of fishing at night by lamplight.
And that brings us to the second way to
examine this painting.
Understanding the actual content of the
scene.
It is of course a night fishing seen in
that light.
At the top is either the moon or an
acetylene gas lamp,
which spear fisherman use to fish to the
surface of the water.
You can see another one under the boat
in the upper left.
We can bet that those two towers in the
massive purple shapes are the Chateau
Grimaldi,
which by the way has since become a
Picasso Museum and the water is the
French Riviera at Auntie,
but resort town in the southeast of
France where Picasso was vacationing in
the summer of 1939.
According to his secretary,
Picasso had come across such fishing
scenes,
walking the town at night after dinner
and proceeded to lock himself in his
studio to work on this really large
canvases,
largest since Garren Aca,
which was completed two years before the
form of night fishing is in keeping with
Picasso's evolving style after Garren
Hca,
which incorporates hold over elements
from the cubist period and the flatness
of the canvas,
and it's emphasis on geometrical shapes,
but it also pulls from the painters
excursions into both surrealism and
primitivism where basis become masks.
Indeed and so much of this painting in
the cubist period and beyond,
the key point to remember is that
figures are painted not as their
perceived but as they're conceived
because so ads to each body elements
that signify to other bodies and to the
canvas as a whole,
and for this reason,
the critic Douglas Morgan is right to
say that we can't call Picasso's people
distorted or grotesque because they
haven't been distorted from anything.
There's no version of reality in which
they're undistorted in night fishing,
that people are not meant to be
sympathized with the normal reaction to
a undistorted figure.
They're meant to be seen that naked.
Seeing that discernment communicates his
meanings more directly and what are
those meetings?
Well,
there are a couple ways we can apply
what we see in form and content to find
out.
First,
it's worth it to look at the historical
context.
The painting was completed in August
1939,
just a couple weeks before the outbreak
of world war.
Two.
Life in Europe was extraordinarily tense
and it was exceptionally so for Picasso
who is still reeling from the sad
conclusion of another conflict,
the Spanish civil war,
and the defeat of the Republican forces
by Francisco Franco and his Nationalist
Army Picasso opposed Franco in his work,
most notably in Guernica,
which is one of the most startling
antiwar paintings in history and in some
ways night fishing and can be seen as a
companion piece to guarantee instead of
depicting all the violence of the former
Picasso shows a moment of hesitation.
The spear is likely to skewer the fish,
but it hasn't yet a moment of choice
opens up and with choice.
There is hope.
The painter draws attention to this by
making the hand gripping the spear,
the most realistic depiction in the
canvas,
and as we move outward from that focal
point,
things become increasingly warped and
yet even with this hesitation,
the scene is suffused with a sense of
almost apocalyptic apprehension.
The light at the top resembles a
spiraling comment as much as it does a
moon or a lamp juxtaposed next to a
frightening blotch of read.
The paintings only use of that color.
The moths are like portents buzzing
around the heads of the fishermen,
the jetty that the women stand on his
unsteady,
the town in the background is a mess.
These feelings could be oppression,
imaging of the coming destruction of
Europe.
Certainly the feeling in the air was
hard to miss,
but more likely these dark undertones
reflect an ongoing personal struggle
with the loss of Picasso's native Spain
to a vicious dictator,
but we're still missing one giant piece
of the puzzle,
the personal context,
what was going on in the artist's own
life in this respect,
it's worth it to ask who these people
could possibly represent.
First,
let's look at the women while they both
seek to get the attention of the
fishermen.
They do so in different ways.
The one closest to them and in the
closest proximity to the light,
spreads her arms in a graceful pose.
The other is more blahzay licking her
ice cream cone.
Her obviously really very obviously
phallic head and pronounced breasts
makes her the more sensuous of the two
and those certainly a massage artistic
distinction.
These two women likely represent
Picasso's wife,
Olga,
and the combination of his mistresses,
Maria Theresa Walter,
and Dora Maar,
who was with Picasso in on team and
finally the spearing fishermen can be
read as Picasso himself or perhaps the
version of himself that he wants to be
headstrong,
looking forward at his goals,
undaunted by distraction,
but this man seems to be linked with his
partner,
perhaps Picasso's other half a side of
himself that is passive that ties a
fishing line to his toe and weights.
Whereas the first fisherman is defined
by strong perpendicular lines.
The second body is a mass of curved
lines and contorted limbs,
remembering the historical context and
the stark defiance that is.
Guess what we might be seeing here is
Picasso coming to grips not only with
passivity and weakness in his nature,
but the artists,
impotence in the face of the world's
brutality.
His mother had died at the start of the
year in Spain was lost.
Maybe this is why the boat floats in a
weird no man's land between the town and
the women.
Maybe this is why the scene feels uneasy
despite being beautiful in its
rendering.
There's more you can read into this
painting and the rest of Picasso's work,
but these five angles always start me
down some fruitful paths and each
individual method of understanding is
less important than the ways all of them
connect and feed into each other.
The historical context usually informs
the personal and the form grows out of
the content,
and your first reaction is often
surprisingly incisive.
If you take the time to voice it or
write it down,
Picasso's legacy looms so large that the
scholarship on him is fast and often
contradictory.
So my feeling is why not decide the
significance of his work for yourself.